all right everybody welcome to the Evan
Carmichael show we are talking about
entrepreneurship I'm excited to have
everybody here on the line again if you
have a question with your business if
you're struggling if you want to talk to
me and get some advice on how to get
your business to that next step I am
here to help you today the number to
call in is one eight eight eight four
five four three three seven eight or you
can also tweet me i am at Evan
Carmichael now to kick off the show I
have some really exciting news this show
is now official a couple weeks ago I
went in and we did a pilot everybody
really liked it thank you guys listening
for calling in and now this is our
official time slot so every second
Thursday at eleven eastern standard
we're going to be talking
entrepreneurship the first thing I want
to talk about is a lot of entrepreneurs
focus on the wrong thing at the start
and they end up failing because of it
when you are first starting the business
the most important thing to think about
is not the big picture is not the
million-dollar idea is not landing that
huge client its survival
entrepreneurship is hard it's one of the
hardest things you're ever going to do
in your life and you need to get to the
point where you have enough money coming
in to support yourself and support your
family and put food on the table you'll
have to go back and get a job working
for somebody that you hate doing work
that's beneath you and watching somebody
else get rich off of your idea the very
first thing you need to do is think
about how can I make enough money to
support myself this isn't glamorous okay
this is a lot of hard work this is
grinding it out every day getting up
maybe not even seen many results coming
in but still every day doing something
to get your business going forward and
you have to learn and to land those
brutally deal even if it's not working
with ideal clients you need to figure
out ways to get to that point of
survival have a little bit of money
coming in so that you don't have to go
back and get that job
right you left that business you left
working for helping for a reason right
maybe you want to be your own boss maybe
you want to live up their own potential
if you want to set your own hours if you
want to create a different life for
yourself and your family those are all
really important reasons and to be able
to get to that point with your company
to make sure you don't fail you have to
be around so phase 1 think about
survival just making enough money to
come in however you do it so you can
still operate another day and I know
it's hard I know it's not glamorous I
know it's not sexy and I remember with
my first business I wanted to work on
those big deal and I spent half a summer
working on this one huge deal that I was
trying to make happen and in the
meantime though we were still banging
these little tiny deals and those don't
get you excited you know we were making
three hundred dollars at a time that
wasn't anything to get all excited about
it and write home about but it kept up
going it gave us a little bit of
breathing room and we weren't
comfortable by any stretch you know if
we had a-something moment to celebrate
we went to mcdonalds having a Big Mac
combo with you know large fries and a
drink that was celebration time for us
so we were now spending a lot of money
we were just basically surviving working
out of my partner's apartment building
going over there every day even our
expenses as low as possible just to give
us the best chance I'd be able to stick
around and still have an opportunity to
grow our business because the last thing
I wanted to do would have to go out and
get a job when I saw so much opportunity
in my business
I didn't want to have to go out and get
a job and work for somebody else and see
somebody else capitalize on my idea I
make big money while I was out working
for somebody else I think that's the
problem for a lot of entrepreneurs as we
see so much opportunity ahead we see so
many things on the horizon what we could
be and we focus only on that and not
about the small step that we need to
take every day to get our business going
a little bit forward most businesses
fail because I've run out of money and
they run out of time you have to make
sure that you're still able to stick
around it's still there too loud for
momentum to grow and build to be able to
let your company get to that next step
okay so this is not common advice
everybody says you know think about that
billion-dollar idea push forward every
day get that that business going but I
don't want you to forget about the idea
it's still important really important
but you have to focus on getting past
survival at the start I want to take
your calls if you have a question you
can call in at 180 days for five four
three three seven eight or you can tweet
me Evan Carmichael we have our first
caller on the line Carrie how you doing
where you're from and how can I help hey
there i'm in dallas texas and i am in
film and television production that's my
business and there is a lot more
production work in Austin than there is
in Dallas the thing is in Dallas I'm not
making enough money to make an easy and
comfortable and you know is straight
forward move to Austin but I really want
to get to Austin for my business some of
my work I can do virtually but the rest
of it I need to be down there
interfacing with people how on a very
shoestring budget can I move my business
and myself to Austin
very question thanks for calling do you
have a family as well that you have to
worry about moving out there no I mean I
need to be proximal because my mom is 80
years old I mean she's still spry but
who knows but I don't have any content I
mean I have some business contacts down
there but I don't have friends down
there that can say come and stay at my
house for 10 days or a month right in
your mom is still in dallas correct
how's the distance how far is it from
dallas austin four hours 200 miles it's
commutable reason it's it's on the edge
of commutable okay it does make sense
how did you start your business here did
you could stop it up I did bootstrap my
business up and I had some ups and downs
with it in my original business was a
little ahead of the curve with internet
radio and video and subsequently that we
couldn't maintain advertisers because
they didn't get the advertising this was
a couple years ago and then and then
when that business closed due to being
underfinanced I went to work for a
corporation where I do production work
for them and I could actually what I do
is scheduling in coordination for
production so I do it either for myself
or when people hire me I do it for them
and right now this is your business full
time you're still working for the
company this i'm still working for the
company but i'm still maintaining a
triple of my own business because i can
use my skill set and become an artist
manager or a talent agent in austin and
there is so much work down there but i
don't know how to get there i don't know
how to restart you know go in with it
because the other comes caveat is that i
had a business closure from my internet
radio and video network and I can't get
a commercial lease that the smart thing
to do when you're small is work out of
your house I guess well i dilute Lee and
you start your first business you have
to quit your job to go and move to
austin to make this happen no but i have
to give them a real good case for
keeping me on although it would be
advantageous to have an Austin presence
down there since there are corporation
and they can't monitor me I don't know
that they
I've fished that to them well I didn't
know what I don't know what I want to
pitch to them I don't know how I can
make this work for them as well as give
me the independence I need well what's
the benefit of them going to austin way
more business way more potential
business for the for their company so
that's the start of your pitch you think
the CEO would buy that well you know
they're there are thirty-five year
corporation and when I talk to him about
it he said oh there's no plans to go
they were considering Houston before
Austin believe it or not which is
unbelievable because Austin you know in
two years 1.36 billion in production
revenue went into ten central texas
counties all right well I hate spending
money until I'm making money it's nice
way to start a business right and it
sounds like you're on the same page here
I would have a frank and honest talk
with with the CEO and let them know hey
you're thinking of leaving you know you
want to be able to get to Austin you
want to pursue your passion and you see
a huge opportunity here with the
business and lay out the case to them
and it's not only a good business
opportunity for them but they get to
keep you on board and in the meantime
you know they're helping pay some of the
bills for you while you can on the
part-time start up your business and
hopefully launch it and choose to
shuttle enterprise well do I divide you
know when I make the pitch shoot and on
compensation do I say this is a salary
position or is it an hour lead position
or do they just pay the overhead for a
small office or house I don't put the
heart don't put the cart before the
horse here you got to get them to
believe in this mission before you go
out and actually discuss compensation if
he's on board if he says yes this is a
good idea let's find a way to make a
work then you can find a way to make it
work if it's hourly or salary or
whatever it is you guys can figure it
out but first you have to make them
believe that this is the path that is
right for both you and for the company
and so in my mind I guess I need to
define more clearly what I want to what
what I'm can do for them as well as what
I'm doing for my own company yes make it
worth their while to go to do it
you're great all right thanks for
calling in I hope you guys I'm on every
two weeks again so if you want to call
in with an update please let me know I'd
love to hear back from you thanks a
little I want to talk about sales
techniques an entrepreneur friend of my
recent came to me and said what sales
techniques can I use the land more
business and if you go online you look
up those techniques you'll find a
million different different names for
things a lot of them are interesting
names you'll find the puppy dog clothes
you'll find poor on the honey- reverse
selling there's a million different
names out there but the most important
sales technique that you need to have is
passion and confidence in what you're
selling reading from a script memorizing
a process is not going to help you
unless you have strong passion in what
you're selling if you don't believe in
what you're selling is no way the people
that you're talking to are going to
believe in you then Walton the founder
of Walmart used to say passion is like a
fever and if you're excited about
something other people will attach it
like a fever and they'll be passionate
excited about it as well so it's not so
much about trying to memorize something
you don't want to be reading from a
piece of paper if somebody gives you a
sales objection you don't want to flip
the page 32 and your manual gives them
the standard answer that's not going to
help all of the sales techniques in the
world will not help you unless you
really believe that what you have is
going to help the top the person that
you're talking to it's so critical if
you don't believe in your product and
let that shine through and everything
you're saying then there's no way you're
going to close that sale I want to get
to the lines again the number here is
one eight eight eight four five four
three three seven eight or me I'm Evan
Carmichael we have Kristen on the line
Kristen where are you from and how can I
help hi I'm from New Jersey welcome to
know what's going on alright so I ever
since I was little I always look going
go-karting and I felt like a lot of the
places i watch so there's like meet my
expectations so I've always wanted like
open up my own
okay so that had like a lot of qualities
I just don't know how to fund it the
right way because I definitely don't
have enough money to do it myself have
you looked into how much it's going to
cost I mean kind of not really i mean
it's just what I know it's gonna cost a
lot you have to find the right land and
everything what my way how is it like
should I get what what made you want to
start this business oh no i've always
liked when I was younger I always love
going to these places and I noticed
there wasn't a lot around like from what
I live currently there's one that's like
45 minutes away and that's the closest
one and I don't know I always I when I
was jumping I always thought those are
so much fun and I always wanted to open
one up and be able to design my own one
okay what do you do right now um i'm
currently in school ok so this is
something you want to do as you get out
of school if your dream yeah yeah or in
the future like something like that but
i just wanted to like start thinking
about how Ike's and like funded and all
that stuff have you ever had any
business experience before no brand new
yes ok it's exciting yeah the first
thing i would actually recommend doing
is thinking about going to work at a
go-kart place before I thought jumping
in and spending all this money and time
to see if you like it ok I don't know if
you've ever done any internships as part
of your school work and you done that
yet yes I have and did you enjoy that
experience yes I did one of the great
things about joint internships is you
cannot really get experience about the
industry but you also get to figure out
is this thing so you're not yeah right
and often you find once you get into the
business that this is this is crazy so
what I wanted at all you know I don't
want I don't want to be in this kind of
business and it's great to figure that
out before you actually dive deep into
it
so my advice but that should be the
start by going to work at one of these
clothes go kart places and see if you
like the business try to get our fellows
to the owner as possible right if he's
an entrepreneur probably you know super
stressed out has tons of things on the
go and if you step up and offer to do
more than what you're just hired to do
you're going to learn a lot about the
business they're going to get skills and
experience and connections that will
help you and also figure out yes do you
want to have this kind of business or
not okay does that make sense no yeah
makes perfect sense am I am i shooting
down your dreams too much here no no
it's fine it's a good start definitely a
good start it is really tough I know you
came in thinking about like how do I get
this funded it is really hard to start
up a business without having any kind of
experience in it and a lot of times do
right and you could you could finance
that you could take out a big loan you
might get friends and family involved
you might get investors involved but if
you don't know what you're doing and the
business end up failing you know you're
going to feel like you let a lot of
people down yeah and I don't want that
for you right i love the opportunity for
you to be able to launch this business
and you know be your own boss and if
this is something you do like next year
or somewhere down the line really
exciting opportunity but i also want to
make sure that it's done right and that
you're happy with it and your friends
and family are happy with it as well
yeah do you see an opportunity anywhere
in there could you do something over the
summer or something you know next year
part-time during school to start
learning about the kill card business I
mean probably more likely at school I
haven't really looked I mean I've only
lost around where they are by my house I
go to school north carolina so I never
really left the seat they're getting
down there but I could definitely do
that okay as you learn about the
business you'll also maybe make some
interesting connections that will help
you grow it with your own company maybe
even the owner of that business will say
hey I really like the ambition of this
employee and if you
you want to open up your own place they
might help you fund it and give you
resources as well you never know what's
gonna happen yeah yeah so you get into
it but I think doing it yourself getting
in that's really experiencing a little
bit will make you more confident and
comfortable and eventually be there with
a laundry room company alright so some
of the best entrepreneurs in the world
that's how they started they started in
turn they learn the ropes it doesn't
have to be something that you spent 10
years working at a go-kart place yeah
but just enough to give you the
experience make some contact and then be
able to help it to that next step aside
if you want to launch it enough yeah did
that help yes it helps a lot thank you
so much all right you know I'm on every
two weeks now so if you want to call
back and give me an update for the
questions just let me know all right
thank you so much all right no problem
thanks the colony all right bye so for
those of you who are like Kristen and
who are thinking of starting the
business it is really important to have
some kind of experience right to know
what you're doing a little bit and some
of the best experience you can get is
working for a company that's already
doing what you want to do you're
basically getting paid to learn about
your business instead of having to take
a course or sign up somewhere or pay or
consultants to help you out you are
getting paid to make mistakes and learn
about the business from somebody else
it's one of the best ways to get some
experience make some contacts make your
early mistakes so that when you're ready
to go launch your business you have it
all lined up you're ready to go your
chances of failure will go down
dramatically because you already know
what you're doing you have easy ways to
hit the ground running the pair's if you
just start up you raise a bunch of money
and you have to give that fall back and
feel guilty those didn't work out we're
going to talk about living a healthy
lifestyle in this segment and I have a
special guest Jamie from Alma set on us
here today Jamie how are you today
wonderful it's great to have you on I'm
a feeling a little bit under the weather
got a little bit of a sniffle in a car
so I'm excited to be talking to you
can you tell us a little bit about about
your company almost said what it's all
about so all the stud is a company from
Germany and we have a brand here in
America and what we have is a great
supplement is a supplement may fit high
protein and that's neither fully
fermented soy we also have yogurt and
honey probiotics and prebiotics and the
protein helps you stay full when you're
using it it's a powder form while you
can make with your favorite drinks like
you know if you like almond mills of
water even even a milk so you can mix it
up and it keeps you full long while
helping you to burn fat and protect your
muscle mass so this is something quick
that entrepreneurs on-the-go can quickly
grab you'll take it it to work don't
have to worry about too much prep time
is that right exactly it's a meal you
can take it with you it's a great way to
get all the nutrition you need without
having to spend a ton of time doing it
you can use it for weight loss I don't
particularly in trying to lose weight
but I love to use it is such a quicker
breakfast for me can you use it for
muscle building as well yes you can use
it for muscle building so if you know do
strength exercises you can use it within
two hours after a workout and that'll
help you you protect your muscles and
also build them as well so I'm a pretty
skinny guy I don't want to lose weight
but I'm really busy and that could be
helpful and I'm trying to put the muscle
on too so that that sounds really
interesting how did you get involved in
the company so I started with something
about three years ago I have a nutrition
background so that's kind of how I got
invited and working with all the third
to really help support the nutrition
side of the product and also help people
decide them on using all the set with
our diet plan so we actually have a diet
plan that people can use that they're
losing weight or they're replacing their
real within
Julie you know they're adding some of
their own meals and helps me with weight
loss but I also help those who are you
know looking for different way of
dieting such as yourself she knows
you're gaining weight you're looking to
gain some weight or muscle mass I help
them use a product the product in a
different way right now is this
something that you would have multiple
times a day or just a breakfast what
does your plan look like so depends when
you're losing weight we recommend to
replace two of your meals that on the
side so you would replace for breakfast
and you would also replace your dinner
and you know you might sound hesitant
but the thing is it gives you full
you're not hungry you're not angry you
know when your angers fueled by hunger
you're a little bit angry and you feel
great because it gives you good energy
and you know what you got 27 grams of
protein and most people aren't even
getting that in their meals so you can
actually replace a meal your heels with
Alma said and that's how people usually
use it now if you're looking to build
some muscle mass you can just add it a
supplement to your diet so if you're
eating you know three times a day your
regular meal you can have your almost
set after your workout got it and this
is now powder then that I would mix in
with a drink is that the idea yeah so
you can mix it into your drink some
people even add it to a smoothie but I
say hey you know watch for the sugars in
the calories so the lighter you make it
and the better weight loss results still
get but of course if you're building
muscle mass it's okay to add a little
bit more calories to it right do you
have any success stories you can share
oh yes absolutely so I have a co-worker
here so i started here three years ago
and when i met her you know she would
come into my office and she would tell
me her goals are what she's looking to
do and you know people talk about their
diets all the time and I didn't know
expect much of it of course you know i
was always be encouraging
three years later she found 70 pounds so
she actually used all the bed and she
stayed on it pretty no rigidly and and
it's just great to see that it's not
right in front of me I mean I can't
literally see her you know from the
other side of my office and this is
amazing she looks like a whole different
person and she you know happier he's
healthier she's in a greater mood so
that's one you know face-to-face success
that I season I also talk to people all
day on the phone and because their
nutrition experts guide them sees our
product and I so many people who have
had great success and using all of a
sudden losing weight but she's a
believer yeah totally and I'm gonna
member okay that's great now a lot of
people have a hard time sticking on
these diet programs right like they
start it up it's great for months and
then one of them falls off the rails how
easy is it to stick to using your
product well what's up do happen and
that's something you have to expect you
know either with dieting or in life that
things might get in the way maybe it's a
holiday or you know you're at your
office and somebody happens to bring
dessert or cookies so what's up not
going to happen and think about its diet
when it makes it what makes it easy to
stick to if it actually makes you feel
good and both you're not craving
anything so you're not giving in to
those flow and you're able to you know
pick yourself up from it very easily so
what's great about all that is you know
if you do happen to slip it's just so
easy to go back on you know all it takes
just no powder water and your favorite
flavors and you mix it all together and
you can just come back onto the diet
what's what's your favorite flavor out
of curiosity so I really like almond
milk with cinnamon and flaxseed it gives
it a nice flavor gatton little bit of
spice from the cinnamon
interesting interesting well that's
great and are there recipes that you
recommend that people can download or
they get with the package yeah
absolutely you can create your own
recipe book you also have recipes online
at all mrs. calm desde el mas bb.com and
you can download it from our website
also comes with all the brochures and it
really guides you through the program
you can also cause directly at one eight
seven seven two five six to seven 33 and
we always have someone on the line that
you can talk to whether you're starting
on the diet or you're in the middle of
the guy and you you really need some
more advice help you keep going that's
great now you talked about if you're
losing weight you want to take it twice
a day instead of your meals what do you
recommend for more of a maintenance
program what's the minimum i guess that
you want to use homicide or the median
silver would just be replacing one meal
a day and keeping your other meals light
and healthy and higher in protein so you
have your beanies you have your whole
grains and also a variety of vegetables
around you know around 500 calories a
meal we have your shape you can choose
which will replace it with which is so
right you know if you have family you
want to eat dinner with your family
maybe you're on the go for breakfast so
you should just replace your breakfast
meal and still enjoy your meals with
your family you see families doing this
together yes I absolutely do I have
people who have tried it themselves and
encourage you know their wife or husband
to use it and they go on a weight loss
program all together and that's great in
itself event and also have parents who
you know go on this diet and also have
maybe their teenager using it as a
supplement not exactly for weight loss
but more of a supportive nutrition while
they're growing that's awesome okay so
we've got two minutes left can you just
quickly tell us maybe a little bit about
how much it costs and where we can find
out more information so almost like you
can
again find on our website on the
information almost as column al ma SE
kaam it comes in a can there's 10
servings in a can at 3795 at $37 and
nine percent so that's about four
dollars a meal so it's hard to find a
full nutritious meal at only four
dollars nowadays so that's a great
investment for your house in your diet
and you can also find our products at
local stores at your local health boards
in GNP that's great thanks so much for
joining us I really appreciate the
information I'm going to check it out
myself too great thank you so much of an
impure to the call if you have any
questions all right I appreciate it all
right bye bye bye so you know I do have
my regular workout routine and I do have
a protein shake so this is this is
interesting and to check it out now I
recently made a big mistake and I want
to talk to you guys about it today I put
on a webinar a couple weeks ago and I
spent a month loading this webinar and
preparing awesome content for it and I
really wanted to go on and help people
this is a free webinar and Tom time of
the webinar everybody's logging in there
ready to go the turn their computers are
sitting down with their their cup of
coffee or whatever it is a press start
and it doesn't work and it doesn't
really matter why it doesn't work the
technology failed on us but all these
people came they set out time of their
busy day you know I'm Spencer have busy
schedules they set it out to come and
listen to my presentation and it didn't
work you can't let customers and
prospects go away unhappy with your
business you have to find a way to make
it up to them somebody was not happy
with an experience I had with your
company are going to tell her the people
some of the people about the bad
experience they had and word of mouth is
so important for entrepreneur right we
can't afford to spend the big budgets
going out and taking out radio eyes and
TV ads we need word of mouth too
help us you have to provide great
experiences but if you make a mistake
you no slip-ups are going to happen
nobody's perfect if you make a mistake
you have to make it up to people and
quite often if you do make a mistake and
you do make it up to somebody that
person is going to become a really loyal
customer you can flip them around I'm
someone is going to bad-mouth you to
somebody who's going to rave about you
so what I did I told everybody I run the
presentation again they wouldn't miss it
I gave everybody a free worksheet that I
normally sell for my website and I
offered them a free one-on-one
conversation with me to talk about their
business that was all for a free webinar
that they missed but you have to go way
above and beyond expectation that's
going to take a lot of time out of my
schedule to help these people out but
it's worth it because you cannot allow
people to walk away from your business
with a negative experience I want to get
your calls again the number is 1 888
four or five four three three seven
eight or you can ask a question on
Twitter I am NOT Evan Carmichael we have
on the line Lisa where are you from and
how can I help i am from fullerton
california welcome to the show what's
going on I have a business it's called
dirty intervention services for f is
paranormal services and I've had it for
the past 30 years has been very low key
detectives now out of the mainstream and
was in the past few years I thought it
the public recently I did it so for pile
the pilot called a haunting one of death
and from that we've got a lot of
response which is really really great
and I have a lot more people to help me
is wonderful but my company is nonprofit
because any money that i use comes out
of my household for my company there now
i have people across the state that ice
never reached because i don't have fun
in order to do it and I need to find a
way to generate involved in my business
so I can help more people that's a very
worthy initiative what kind of stuff to
do with your nonprofit I'm a psychic
medium and I specialize in excision and
cleansing so if they have a ghost or
spirit problem or demonic column I go on
and take care of it for them okay and
that has to be you have to go to
somebody's house trailer guys this
travel time and natural consequences
nice afternoon over the past 30 years
for the clients I can't guess who I can
keep them via the Internet what do okay
what I would like to do is do an EVP and
it lets apps in turn use the cells put
back into the business in order to help
people and get them hopefully and are
you charging for this service of yours
when you go out okay okay because I
believe someone's than getting a gift
that they need to return the favor and
help other people I haven't heard
certain years I never intend to fun so
here's the thing a lot of people want to
help people and that's part of any
enterprise if it if its profit or
nonprofit but if you are making money
you're going to be able to help more
people right look if you're not still
able to support yourself we ought to be
able to help that many people anymore
exactly that's why I thought if maybe I
could find a way of getting a batter
which I don't know how to do that to
help me you know some o the DVD and make
a DVD to get it out there and it can't
confirm they get their profit back and
then we have money back into the
company's I can use other people are you
full on your schedule or ours is there a
lineup that use your services it comes
variety sometimes I'll have four points
in a week sometimes I won't have any
sometimes I'll have yet it only depends
because it's much patience each business
so the first point I made in this show
was about survival right you have to
make enough money to make sure that
you're still around you can put food on
the table and I know it's a challenge
that sounds like you're facing you know
right now it keeps his business going
nonprofit business going so you got to
find a way to bring money into the
company a couple ways that you might be
able to do it one is I know you want to
give this all for free to people but
it's going to limit your ability to help
more people right if you are not able to
pay your bills you're not going to be
around to help people so maybe have a
cap maybe say the first five of the week
or the month are free but then beyond
that it costs whatever it is on your
dollar $200 something some nominal fee
at least to support you know the
electricity running a year place if you
want to look at other products of dvds i
would put the word out the people you've
already helped because these guys all
have connections and i'm sure that they
feel very grateful to you for the work
you've done to them am i correct yeah
like you've helped them with a major
problem right and we get letters of SATA
to do all the time how they found their
life back and how grateful they are and
state courts them your clients to me
it's the most rewarding thing is
something them and getting their lives
back and it feels great right to know
you help these people mm-hmm yeah and
I'm sure they'd love you so why not
write to them let them know what you're
doing I'm sure somebody who you've
helped either has made a DVD themselves
or has a contact who can help make a DVD
will do for you either a low-cost or
no-cost or some kind of partnership
you've built this community up you
should use it to help you grow your
business does that make sense I never
really thought of that okay we're
bumping up against the clock but I hope
you'll apply that's your business I'm
here every two weeks though if you want
to call back and tell me about your
progress that be happy to help you out a
little bit more people think
participated no problem good luck with
the business and for everybody else who
is trying to bootstrap your company look
to your community if you have helped
customers or if your nonprofit you have
at this base of people who you've helped
both the way today might be able to help
you out as well get your next step thank
you everybody so much have had so much
fun it's crazy how
faster time always flies but I am here
every two weeks so two weeks from now
I'm going to be on again tall in go
visit my website of our caramel calm and
i will see you guys soon take care